really nice guys III almost started
crying I almost started crying when
there was a kid in my front row with his
mom and he had a cane and he was blind
and temping he was laughing his ass off
and then he came up to me and said 23
and he lost his sight at 19 his mother
and he said you your podcast stopped me
from killing myself Jesus Christ said
you guys stop me from killing mice did
he say did he say listen I listen to
Brian couch show I want to kill myself
my kid saved my life no that's not what
he said no that's what he said that's
not what do you say when you're on your
own
I thought about slit my wrists no and
why not let's just show I thought this
they ever heard that's not what he
thought let's define kidding no no
that's not no sure no that's not what he
said you can't no credit Connie no I
feel like I feel like you're using his
loss of slang you're welcome nope
welcome blind I feel like you're losing
it using his loss of sight to justify my
insult it's not cool
no that's not cool I don't think it's
cool to him but he said to me 19 years
old he he has a condition it's
hereditary well he lost his sight his
nerves died in his eyes and his mother
looked at me and said yeah he was gonna
kill himself he's at your PI stuff said
said you keep in touch they're putting
so I don't know if you listen to the
Rogen thing with David Sinclair where
they are they're reversing a blindness
and mice crushed the optic nerve yep
they're doing it with viruses he's on a
trial he's in a trial phase where they
get shot a virus in his [ __ ] eye
hopefully it [ __ ] yes yes trying to do
the same [ __ ] they do with mice with his
eye they will do this they will in in
the next 10 years they're going to have
it oh ho pls see again I told him that I
said be watching someday they're gonna
be able to see that okay but don't do it
he's giving you a thumbs up I hope he's
listening wish I knew the kid's name
giving you a double ring is up and
holding it can't see that I nobody well
he's back in LA alright there's no doubt
there's no doubt he'll get his [ __ ] yeah
man that's cool yeah if you ever seen
the videos those that make make make me
cry a kid here in very first time named
for the first I start crying they put
the thing like and then they're like
let's see if it works gonna be like
Joshua and he's like
like oh [ __ ] and the kid starts crying
yeah did you ever have a movie do you
guys ever have a movie one movie that
changed the way you lived your life to
where you saw a movie and you went oh I
gotta make a change what was it really
that's infusion that whatsit as well
yeah I don't know what it was that
that's interesting what about it no it's
a great movie mask it's a great movie
what was it was it cuz he was different
the different thing than the love story
and then also music Danny Elfman do the
music was amazing Oh Danny Elfman yeah
giant yeah what about you Kat that's
interesting cat I mean to answer from
the it's a rillette I was not expecting
that
Edward scissors cat they were moving I
think it was Radio the Cuba Gooding jr.
one there was the first movement with
the weird though yeah that's the first
move that ever made me cry and I was so
embarrassed watching it with my mom that
I was crying I don't highlighter I was
like oh he's kind of different yeah he's
like oh he's a special he's like simple
Jack yes if you want me to not watch a
movie you have an actor you haven't
actor do that and I'll never watch it
know that I I know you're talking about
that one I'm sure he's great he really
went on a limb here though yeah I'm sure
he was amazing I think I'm really he
really pushes his there's not a scotch
no he's simple Jack watch lately the
radio never seen that never snow simple
Jack's Ben Stiller in was that a comedy
or was that no no he simply picked under
Tropic Thunder that's him oh yeah I'll
never watch that and Sean ended Sean
Penn did a movie right but that's all
funny right yeah how was it when Sasso
was in here
hilarious singing he drove me crazy at
first and then and then it just kicked
off then we killed of course he showed
up on time only a half-hour late and
that just half hour for wills that's
good it's actually good usually look at
our two hours no it's a statics astonish
normally play volleyball in Marina del
Rey and each up choosing about our three
hours late and we'd be like oh we're
yeah we're leaving well yeah what's
although breeze like I just got here huh
drive me
just come eat with us yeah but it would
be dressed in plays volleyball he's
always the best is he by the way
and we started weird he was singing I
was like what's going on maybe he's out
of his mind and then after 25 minutes he
kicks in is [ __ ] genius he's just he
to me here I always say it
he Zack Galifianakis and Artie Lange
before he got into drugs and Will Sasso
the funniest people I've ever met
naturally an off the cuff but will might
be number one
like overall if you just take our grand
link the LEAs all this Julie it's
phenomenal and you yeah it's okay to my
Brides all right I've had my moments
have had I've had a good run I think it
right
yeah his game is hard right and I was
like yeah he's killing it right there
like his shoe game is hot and then I
looked at the camera girl but I'm og
yeah you use original it goes you Chris
then me yeah Chris it was so funny
because Chris you know when he's open
for me I didn't know that yeah yeah I
took Chris on the road and um because I
thought the ha you saw him at the
economy store I saw him at the ha ha ha
and you're like that kids talented I saw
he must have been doing it a year and a
half Wow and I saw him and I was like
when he got offstage Jason Collins
introduced me to him and then I went in
Psalm at the ha ha and and I just walked
up to him you know we were already
friends and I go hey you want to go on
the road with me and for a year and
about it a little over a year he went on
the road with me Wow
yeah we were crushing her I was you know
I was already getting like you know I
was already selling out weekend I'm in
here it goes this it's probably 11 years
ago
damn yeah it's all Chris that's so cool
man yeah for a year yo he'd go it was so
funny Chris was gonna be like at I knew
is gonna be the bet I kept telling Jamie
Masada I was like what are you doing
like this guy needs being in the laughs
actor what are you doing nah buddy he's
not ready I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about disguiser come on like I
took him on the road and I love putting
people in front of me that are [ __ ]
strong but what
like following people that are like me
how I find it funny when comics do that
yeah with a sandbag where they'll put a
bro like bro you see it too don't you
see I'm like because as I hate it I was
a fan of cambia fire I do it so you want
the you want the audience have the best
show possible always if you put [ __ ] in
front of you yo it doesn't really make
you look better no like God those guys
were awful awful the crowds kind of off
it's not yeah see you know what I'm
talking about I don't want to see any
news there's a lot of guys that do that
I take that personally sandbag the show
oh I take a guy named Eric post and he's
a dork at the Comi store uh I want I
want to say Who but big name counts that
we know would bring him he crushes yeah
they don't bring him anymore I don't get
it yeah I I have to have someone that
crushes and juvenille see that yeah so I
I have veneers well all of our veneers
but ty fell on a rock when I was a kid
and that's why I got the veneers and
then uh the the the stud that was in
here
collapsed two days ago and then they had
to rip it out of my mouth and reach yeah
so because that is stud in there since I
was like like 13 when I fell on the rock
and it's you know the material they were
using back then was like steel or
something not healthy and it collapsed
so all this has been ripped out and they
put new ones every days ago they put new
more teeth in two days it's nice yeah
they put new ones in yeah there's these
are all temps I get my new ones in two
week that's it's gonna hurt when they
put that in yeah there's any worse than
mouth pain oh nothing
how about like tooth problem thank God
for modern day dental oh my god what did
we do I know what we did we lost our
teeth I was at when I was in Tempe
Arizona
this guy had that's exactly what
happened it just ripped it out it's not
whose teeth are the third ones in yeah
who is that that is [ __ ] rat
[ __ ] what is so you know what that is
that's when they file the Tia combin
ears yes oh you're [ __ ] yeah they
filed all of mine like that yeah it's
all I'm not but now I'm missing teeth
I'm not doing what do you think this was
gonna get veneers amount that hurt do
you think this guy right here ever says
um what is it that you don't like about
me is the last fight you're in oh god if
there's one thing I hate worse than my
fighting it's his fire yeah in the ring
in the ring just looking like a fight I
mix it up in the ring bro do you mix it
real straight I love it when do have you
been in a fight Chicago is the last
fight how long ago is that about ten
years ago yeah well do you know why cuz
you're too grown yeah what happened I
forget me it was just stupid
drunk Steve burn got uh how did you know
my son 16 so he was six at the time yeah
I think that's what I knew so the FBI is
watching you dude oh yeah you're not a
big drug guy are you Joe
yes he is not [ __ ] drug and I don't
do drugs drugs all that time oh yeah
what about when you dude your eyes are
shifting back yeah you mean lick my lip
your lips are giving me I come here for
some cocaine no Joe don't do it again
dick that's all I don't really like
doing drugs I like doing the things you
have to do to get drugs okay I got it I
didn't want that you don't want the
cocaine but I suck your dick god excuse
didn't you just keep the cocaine
doing the dirty and you don't really
okay mikesblog they don't feel gay yeah
yeah I'm straight enough to like blow
and therefore I do yeah man but have you
ever done any of that stuff or no yeah I
think I did in the past
I don't not your thing no my brothers my
brother is crazy and I saw a lot of
drugs it doesn't work out for anybody
that you know when you're over 30 doing
growls yeah I don't understand that it
just doesn't nobody did a lot of cocaine
nobody had problems or was broken did a
lot of cocaine then it got better it
never happened in the history of the
world yeah
nobody did a lot of cocaine and started
a business even though you want to start
a business when you're doing it nobody
did anything I mean that I had a friend
that had a couple sushi restaurants both
of them gone
- cocaine yeah bad that bad I remember
him closing the windows to his
restaurant trying to hurry up and get
everybody out so you just do blow a
party going yeah I said this was really
your life man and I sounds a little done
stop talking to him
yeah you got a kind of suction I could
hang candidate or you can't just just
always a party can't be around as a
party while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gets a gift it's a gift